i am-ness Tosa video director of the
Center for the Study of globalization
and it is my great pleasure this
afternoon to introduce Robert Zoellick
who is president of the World Bank but
before we impress him at the World Bank
let me tell you he has had sold so many
positions of responsibility I guess you
were still a very young man while you
are still a young man and even younger
person when we you started to serve at
the deputy assistant secretary and
counselor to the secretary at the
Treasury Department you went to the
State Department to see to surface
Undersecretary of Economic Affairs serve
as deputy chief of staff at the White
House to lead the US official 2+4
process of German unification you were
Sherpa to the US president for the
preparation of economic summits in 91
and 92 and more recently in this century
you have served as United States Trade
Representative when you launch or
concluded a number of foreign trade
agreements between the United States and
many countries you work very hard if we
will speak about that to have the Doha
round launch later you serve as deputy
secretary at the State Department and
since July 2007 you have been the 11th
president of the World Bank I know that
when you haven't been called to public
service you have
also done for obvious reasons work in
the private sector and you have been I
am told also very successful in those
brief periods in the private sector so
you have proven to be capable of you
know doing work in the private sector of
making good income so let me start with
this question Bob so why have you given
so many years of your professional life
to public service rather than staying
where the money is well I'll answer the
question but first I have to share with
all of you that the part of my
background that president Zinio left off
that is when I'm particularly proud on
is that I work very closely to make sure
that the United States negotiated with
Mexico for the North American Free Trade
Agreement which is where our first
encounter Ernesto's a deal because at
the time I when I was at the Treasury
Department we'd work on the canada-us
free-trade agreement but and some of us
had wished and hoped the possibility of
free trade with Mexico but for
historical reasons it clearly couldn't
come from the United States so when it
came from Mexico this to me was
critically important not only for
economic issues but frankly for the
transformation that was taking place in
Mexico and the modernization of Mexico
the movement of Mexico to democracy in a
sense is this is a way of backing into
the question I've always had a very
strong interest in history it's really
my my true love and reading and if you
think about something that many
Americans often don't think about which
is the historical perspective that
countries will bring to issues many
Americans overlook the fact that Mexico
lost 1/3 to 1/2 of its territory to the
United States and that was a very deeply
felt loss so this was a huge
transformation at Mexico and I've been
honored to
work with a know Ernesto since then
because he is the president who helped
consolidate that and indeed brought
Mexico through to democracy which is
quite a historic achievement so I all of
you are very fortunate to have him here
I've also known him it's somebody who
knows a great deal about economics and
governance and the real reason I'm here
is because he did a project for me
putting together an international
commission looking at some of the
governance issues of make and just so
you have a sense of his sense of duty is
that in return he said no you have to
come up to Yale so so that's that's how
we were trading confesses this is the
first time I come to just I and my point
of him Schmidt you know I just I was met
with some students just last week I came
back from Germany and Britain and
Switzerland and week before that I was
in India so I travel an awful lot but
while I've driven past New Haven and
taken the train this is a terrible thing
I've never been to Yale so this is a
wonderful opportunity for me to come and
that reference actually is in as a way
of answering your question I grew up
with a very strong interest in history
and for me the sense of both patriotism
and what could give to one's country was
the highest calling and and and over
time also the the issues and challenges
were most interesting so having worked
in the private sector and while I've
great great value I think sometimes
sometimes people in the private sector
who assume government is so easy and how
comes problems aren't solved don't
recognize that the complexity of not
only trying to think through the policy
but the institutional the political the
communications aspects make achievement
in that field sometimes even more
challenging and I've had the good
fortune of dealing with this
internationally as well and it's the
same set of issues we've got different
generations here but for me you know and
I think there's still influences my
thinking about the World Bank and multi
issues and trade you know I grew up in
the era of thinking about the u.s.
effort after World War two to create a
different international order and system
and so early on I would have seen the
GATT and the IMF and the Bretton Woods
is partly the economic institutional
lessons of the failures of the interwar
period so that was kind of what put me
on the course and then as probably for
many people in this audience serendipity
is important in life which is that I had
the opportunity to work for some very
talented people from whom I was able to
learn and one of the things that I chose
in terms of professional work was to try
not always just to pick the institution
but to try to pick people who I could
work with and learn from and happened to
me actually of both political parties
inside and outside government which
helped me try to get a better sense of
how I could perform and then the last
part of it is for me it became a
multidisciplinary approach so while I
studied history I also stayed a lot of
economics at some point I also branched
into finance tried to learn something
about politics and governance as we were
talking at a lunch session about climate
change and others try to figure out how
other disciplines can be integrated so I
tend to think about problems in an
interdisciplinary sense okay so public
service vocation but I think there's a
common denominator in your public
service career and that is interest in
international relations interest in the
way in which the United States interacts
with the rest of the world interest and
commitment towards international
cooperation and with no offense to your
country men and women I do find a lot of
people in this country that do have a
public service vocation but simply don't
care about the rest of the world
why do you
I think well you know a lot of it
depends on opportunity and let me just
give you a factual example maybe sort of
humorous in the in the context of
subsequent events I worked at the
Treasury Department for James Baker from
85 to 88 I had not been involved with
politics but then I worked in the
campaign of George Bush for 41 in in
1988 and frankly the day I joined we
were 18 points down but I thought this
would give me an opportunity to learn
something about Americana and
policymaking and it's something we've
talked about is that for all the work on
policy understanding in a democracy how
politics affects policy and how to deal
with those I think is a very useful
thing and if you're in my work I've
often done with US Congress and US
Congress is elected they're looking for
things back home and so you have to have
an understanding of those things but my
point is when I then went to the State
Department actually there were some news
stories saying well this guy only knows
about domestic stuff because at that
point I was dealing with domestic
financial issues and others it so
happened that I had had a lot of
interest and read a lot about
international affairs but one point here
is that sometimes you know people
because of the need to specialize take
one track or the other I actually find
that people are most effective in
international affairs particularly as
they represent our country are helped if
they know something about their own
country in their own politics in their
own sense of the challenges second I
guess then coming back to you know
people's interests I mean you have this
sense from Mexico the United States is a
big country it's easy you know to get
absorbed in the challenges of business
in this market the politics in a local
level and not have the international
connection my own view is that's
changing so we were talking about you
know Yale now versus the time that I was
going to college from 71 to 75 I went to
a place called Swarthmore the number of
international students you have here has
very much changed the dynamic I think
much too the better you know some of
this actually deals with the
mieze of communication and movement I
mean this will be maybe a shock to some
people but I grew up in Illinois when I
went to high school I studied German as
much as a cultural connection because my
family was of German heritage I never
thought I'd use German because I never
thought I would be on a jet airplanes
were for wealthy people to go places and
so to me German was like math this is no
offense to the math students here but
it's an interesting discipline but I
never could quite understand as I got to
the higher levels of math how I was
gonna use it now this is a tremendous
irony when I say this to my European
friends I can tell they smiled benignly
but they don't comprehend it but you
know if you grew up in those
circumstances you didn't necessarily
expect to travel now the irony was this
is I guess loose Hall I got a loose
fellowship and went to Hong Kong first
so I actually lived abroad briefly in
Asia before spending time in Europe and
I think now for people growing up it's
different they have a much better sense
of the possibilities of travel it's more
it's an easier thing to do and broader
communication certainly internet and
other things would broaden that but I I
guess part of it is coming back to a
point I do think there's a challenge for
those of us interested in America's role
in the world to continue to press how
this is serves America's values its
interests and we could go into that
whether it's security or economic or
other aspects and also increasingly with
the world we're going to be living in
the benefits to also learn from others
we've talked about in the context of the
World Bank the field of development is
no longer a north/south question of
charity or solidarity but it's
increasingly south south or south north
there's things you can learn more
broadly so I don't find this to be a
difficult case to make in the business
community people understand markets and
they understand the US while it
represents 20 to 25 percent of world GDP
is 4 to 5 percent of population to think
about emerging markets with growth
opportunities but you're right still in
some political context
you have to explain the broader boards
you have you have seen closely the
evolution of the global economy in the
last 30 years but you will agree with me
that perhaps the hardest test of the
international economic system and the
global economy as we know it today a has
occurred over the last two or three
years with the crisis that started more
evidently in the fall of 2008 we were on
the eve of perhaps the worst financial
collapse known in human history we had
the deepest recession in onine mostly
that we have cut in the world six or
seven decades we have the strongest
collapse in international trade that we
have had in in 40 years so where are we
now
after this big desk I mean how do you
see I mean you look back to the crisis I
mean what happened and where are we not
now well
just a slight hinge and given your
opening point I think one always has to
be a little careful of current
historicism you put it in the
international context and maybe the data
will bear you out when I think about
growing up in say 1968 in the trauma in
the United States in 1968 Vietnam War
Bobby Kennedy Martin Luther King getting
shot urban I mean so when some people
say oh these are the most difficult
times even in my lifetime I can find
someone that at least close seconds but
but economically and it's a relevant
point in that obviously what was
happening in the international economy
led to 1971 the end of the Bretton Woods
system
you're you're definitely correct in
terms of looking at some of the scope of
the downturn I think that where we are
now is a multi-speed recovery and this
will fit into some of the challenges so
for most of the emerging markets not
necessarily Central Asia or Eastern
Europe but for most of the emerging
markets the challenge now is they've had
pretty strong recoveries and the
question is leveling off so as to avoid
to avoid overheating inflation asset
price bubbles and each country faces
different circumstances on why but I
think most of them are recognizing and
acting on them in the case of the United
States while I believe there's a
reasonable recovery I actually think it
might even be a little stronger than
some forecasts they're still going to be
a serious problem in creating jobs to
reduce unemployment rate and there's
this big wave of deficit and debt that I
believe is more serious than in the past
it's gonna have to be dealt with in the
case of Europe it's a question of
dealing with the sovereign debt crisis
and then making sure that whatever
solution allows Europe as a political
economic entity to move forward together
for all these regions though another
point that I try to emphasize is the
importance of focusing on the
fundamentals of growth whether it be
called structural or micro economic
because what I've described in the first
part are some of the cyclical recovery
aspects the sort of the macroeconomic
demand elements and I think it's
important for policymakers to keep their
eye on on these growth fundamentals now
the challenge that that's going to
provide is that policymakers in
different countries are seeing different
issues as priorities and you know in a
crude sort of metaphor it's like
tectonic plates run
into each other in different rates and
not surprisingly that shows up in
discussions where economies run into
each other such as monetary policies or
exchange rate systems and if it's not
handled going back to multilateral
cooperation effectively you could see
very you could see risks that could grow
protectionism conflicts over with
different capital flow issues depending
on how people manage the recovery other
aspects that fall into that could have
social dimensions one that I've been
watching quite closely as the food price
issue and I think we're gonna face both
a secular trend and food price increases
but also some increased volatility which
comes back to the point that what I
think marks the system and I tend to
think this not only in pure economic
terms but I've been thinking in
political economy terms is what I
described at the bank is we're having to
modernize multilateralism we're having
to make multilateralism work in a
different era so if you come back to
your point about you know when I went to
to college and graduate school it was
understanding the lessons from the
interwar period that the United States
tried to create with the Bretton Woods
institutions and in that international
system and how they were adjusting in an
oil shock world and other sort of the
stagflation of the 70s well now it's a
question of how do these institutions
adapt and in some ways there's a much
bigger seismic change which is the rise
of emerging markets and so I refer to
this as a new multipolarity frankly we
studied multipolarity when I was going
to graduate school but I the new part is
today about half of global growth here
from emerging markets and that's a very
different dynamic than even ten years
ago but this crisis has accelerated some
trends that already existed or
is sort of retarding some trends I mean
you speak about modernizing
multilateralism and in fact when the
crisis erupted with great force one of
the first reaction by countries was to
create a g20 so in a way that was a
signal that leaders were saying yes we
need to be more coordinated with it more
international cooperation and I think at
the beginning some of the things that
were decided by the g20 particularly the
most relevant members of it were in the
decisions in the right direction
however as the crisis sort of is one can
see that some of those commitments that
were made at the g20 have not been
honored so the question is whether we
can go back to business as usual and I
still have the kind of you know recovery
that can be sustained and addressed the
issues that certainly are felt at the
national and local level but that need
at least a molecule of international
coordination let me try to address this
at a couple of different levels first I
think it's understandable that
international partners when they felt
they had the back against the wall or
worse turning to the precipice would
have a greater sense of cooperation
which they did with expansionary
policies different types in different
countries a book that I I commend as
this one about this time it's different
which is the book about looking at
centuries of financial crises and you
can kind of see what flows from them and
by raghavendran hurt right Reinhart was
a visitor at my Center last semester
yeah there you go we're ready huh and
and Ken Rogoff is at Harvard but
but fit anyway and before that the IMF
which is kind of like Harvard you know
it's so but one of the things that they
clearly alerted the world to was that
after you have that quick response you
often have a problem of sovereign debt
management and there's other things that
will kind of flow from this depending on
the nature of the crisis this actually
goes to the point about my observation
about multi-speed is you get it two
different types of problems people are
going to have to come up with different
policies and part of the challenge will
be how national or regional policies
will meet their interests without
causing burden or clashing with others
or how you manage those differences a
second level of observation is it in my
experience the world rarely moves
through step functions there are there
are a few I lived through one the end of
the Cold War but it normally is a series
of incremental changes and the challenge
of policy making is moving the
incremental changes to move and with
some sense of a strategic framework and
let's take one of those you mentioned
the g20 and this gives people a little
feel to about how these things happen in
fact the g20 was actually around for
about ten years before that but it was a
group of finance ministers that had been
created and in late 2008 President Bush
43 had met with the g7 finance ministers
and I was there because they had the
head of the IMF and World Bank and some
of us actually said to some people
privately in the White House look given
the nature of this crisis you need a
broader group
you really got have to figure out how to
reach out to the emerging markets and
coincidentally there was a meeting of
the g20 finance ministers in Washington
and so President Bush arranged to come
to speak to the g20 finance ministers
that led people to think of that as a
potential group and then they had the
first summit in Washington and then
London and others that followed moving
up to the summit level now what was in
the works was I had given a speech about
a year before
saying that the g7 doesn't isn't isn't
sufficient as a as a as a policy group
and I was working with ideas about like
a group of 15 or 16 so would this 20
have been necessarily the ideal group
well yes or no but it clearly had to
expand for some of the emerging markets
now this is where political institutions
and economies then interconnect well
what about the g20 can it take on these
roles so you're talking about and my
first observation about the g20 is that
it's a group for our era because the
numbers don't add up there's actually
more than 20 and so the people as usual
the Europeans while they talk about
acting as a queen of Europe having eight
or nine members even its famous huh but
there's also for those of you that are
interested in international politics
there's some other interesting
dimensions for example some they drew
some things that we did in the trade
area which is they will have
representatives of some regional groups
asean a couple times APEC some ones from
Africa and this is a tension you always
see in an international system which is
more more people makes it more
representative and therefore legitimate
but the more people the harder it is to
get things done and so I think one of
the challenges for the g20 going forward
will be whether it will just be as some
of the Indians said when I was there
recently a talk shop or whether it will
try to drive issues now then there's
questions about how it should operate
some people have said the g20 should
create a Secretariat I think this would
be a mistake I think would make it too
institutionalized bureaucratic and what
I have argued for is they should use the
current institutions the World Bank the
IMF the WTO and this has another benefit
which is if you're not in the g20 then
you say why are these guys deciding for
me and so I have a G 187 I have 187
countries that are represented on the
board and so this would interconnect a
broader membership but also it would
allow upgraded multilateral institutions
to help identify issues anticipate
problems come up with different
solutions and just to give you a
practical sense of this I saw president
Sarkozy in late in December right before
Christmas
he's been talking about some areas like
food price volatility and monetary
system and so I tried to come up with
some practical suggestions about ways we
could deal with these issues one of
which I wrote in the FT in January
another which I'll probably write about
the monetary system before too long as
well so it's a question of how you can
adapt international institutions but
coming back to your point Alton and in a
sense dealing with the crisis many of
you will have studied the League of
Nations well the League of Nations was
another international institution but
ultimately it failed because it wasn't
effective it didn't you know so every
country at a vote u.s. wasn't one of the
countries that was there but even
without the US the question is you know
will institutions be legitimate even if
they have participation if they don't do
things so one of the arguments that I've
made in the g20 would be you need to
focus on action it's better if action
deals with the problems that people are
seen in the real day and even better if
it deals with some of the problems for
non g20 countries and some of the issues
for food price issues and you can't do
everything so I've my concept of this
was always the g20 is more of a steering
group working with other parties and
institutions than some hierarchical
system so I've reached a little bit into
you know political economy institutions
but and because those are the vehicles
by which actions get pursued but one
needs to keep your eye on the policy
agenda now one that you and I both have
a strong interest in would be having
launched the Doha round the completion
of the Doha round would clearly be a
very important thing for the world
economy and the institutional system as
a whole where I've had differences with
some is I also believe you can
complement this with various regional
integration or free trade agreements and
how they can also support an agenda so
um I think when you come back to your
question about the crisis we're in a
different stage now we're certainly not
through it and ultimately this will
depend on the wisdom and success of
governments taking the appropriate
actions Wow
I represent a multi-level institution
I'm used to the u.s. system the u.s. is
still a very big player in the
international economy and so the US will
face some key decisions in my view also
about spending and deficit and debt that
will be important not only for the US
and for the u.s. is role in the
international system but will be
important for the international system
well but let's take two concrete issues
of which the g20 took specific
commitments a1 and we'll deal with train
later one first one the so-called global
macroeconomic imbalances some people
believe that at the root of the a 8:09
crisis was these global macroeconomic
imbalances meaning one large country
like the US I mean a large current
account deficit meaning absorbing too
much savings from the rest of the world
and more specifically from a few
countries and more specifically from
countries like China where as a group of
countries like China like Japan like
Germany having large current account
surpluses and this as experiencial is
not sustainable the leaders at the g20
acknowledge this as a very serious issue
since the first meeting in Washington
than in London and then in Peaks were
they established in a very solemn way
that they were going to do whatever
would take to have in the future
conditions for balanced growth and
prevent the reappearance of these global
macroeconomic imbalances and yet here we
are a year and a half later after pics
work and in practical terms
nothing has been achieved to
structurally address these global
macroeconomic imbalances the Monday that
was given to the IMF at pics were
probably was he been weaker than the
Monday that had been given by finance
ministers three or four years earlier to
the
IMF before they capped these
multilateral surveillance and in pics
were they launched this you know
framework for growth to say okay now you
let's cap some sort of peer review and
nothing has happened a and it's not
because this is a g2 issue I don't think
it is a g2 us-china issue this is really
a multilateral problem you have been
talking also about the problem of Brazil
which is part of the global
macroeconomic imbalances this situation
in Europe what is it there is it that
domestic political forces make it very
hard for countries to do these
modernization of multilateral
instruments because in a way they will
have to be back so I'm sober enmity that
seems untouchable by domestic political
system what is the problem why we cannot
move in the direction that
intellectually it seems to be obvious
you could frame it that way I'd frame it
slightly differently and this even will
connect to your opening question about
understanding one's own home economy and
political economy we still live in a
world of sovereign states Europe is the
farthest along in terms of having a
notion of shared sovereignty but we even
see the crisis in Europe and dealing
with the fiscal and monetary aspects of
that that's a reality that sovereignty
and that means that governments are
going to make decisions and have to sell
decisions and whether in a democratic
process with their legislatures be able
to get the votes for decisions that
reflect the sovereign national interest
but in a world that's interdependent and
integrated and interconnected the first
thing to do is in much of policy or life
is avoid bad things okay so you know
avoid blaming your country's problems on
everybody else avoid coming up with
protectionist solutions avoid coming up
with things that then say oh you know
our problems are due to you and whether
it's immigration or some other issue and
cutting yourself off and
I'll make a little perspective from the
US I think one of the us's strengths
over the centuries has been that it's a
society that is open to ideas and goods
and capital and people and I think
that's probably America's ultimate
strength because if things go wrong and
policies are off as they will be in any
country it helps correct it more quickly
than others that are closed societies so
a small modest point is that while we
haven't closed the Doha round we haven't
done things like in the 30s in terms of
trade protection and we shouldn't ignore
that because that took work took work by
people like Pascal Lamy at the WTO
myself others for sort of identifying
this as a potential risk and kind of
blowing whistles when things happen but
on the core issue that you mentioned
people will there's monetary aspects but
but one should keep in mind the monetary
issues are really a reflection of the
fundamental economics and so one of the
issues we could come back to is I do
believe that even the international
monetary system will evolve and there's
a role for trying to set norms and
encourage flexible exchange rates
autonomous monetary policies role the
IMF and others but the fundamental issue
that you're talking about will come down
principally to the US and China changing
that consumptions and savings balance
now the good news is the Chinese
recognize the issue the Chinese say our
model of development which was based on
heavy export led growth and had high
levels of domestic savings and low
consumption we need to shift that now
before we be too critical let's
recognize I've had this discussion for
20 years with Japan which also relied on
export led growth and they never really
made the switch it's not so easy to make
the switch the Chinese will have this in
the next five-year plan there are
aspects that relate to reducing savings
that in the household sector reflect the
fact that people have to save for health
and education and pensions but what many
people may not be aware of is that the
savings rates in China
in the household sector not that
different than they are in India they're
higher than they are in the US but but
not that much about the same as India
the real savings rate comes from the
retained earnings of large companies
that were often had preferred positions
got very attractive financing from banks
that paid very little to depositors and
many of them kept these was retained
earnings now this is where part of the
challenge of international diplomacy or
economic diplomacy or policymaking is
saying to China well if you want to have
a more harmonious society if you want to
have more inclusive growth there are
aspects that you will want to change in
terms of health benefits education
benefits others but also the structure
of your economy that would remove some
of these advantages that create the high
savings rate and by the way in some of
these sectors if you create more
competition you'll improve the
productivity you'll create more jobs
these are in some service sectors and
you'll make China into a wealthier
economy over time and you might also
open those markets and create additional
opportunities for say service sector
from developed economies now I have that
discussion with the Chinese to a degree
the US does will it happen overnight no
will it happen quickly enough well
probably not quickly enough for one
would like but the question is can we
push in that direction similarly on the
US side the US also has a savings
consumption and balance so the u.s. also
has to try to face some of the
structural issues that are going to have
to be dealt with with entitlement
programs so let me give you a one than a
nonpartisan way you know that you hear
both parties and Congress and the
president talking about discretionary
spending I mean all of you should be
aware discretionary spending in the
budget is actually quite a modest
proportion it's the entitlements program
Social Security is an issue that while
it's not the biggest entitlement it's
significant it would certainly signal
the United States coming together to
deal with a problem and everybody knows
the key variables they're not too
complicated at this point I mean you
could deal with about 60 to 70 percent
of the problem by changing the wage
index for inflation to a Consumer Price
Index you could change the retire
in age if you could do this in ways that
emphasize progressivity so I've been
trying to urge both sides to say this
would be a good one to send a signal of
dealing with the United States
structural issue and by the way I think
it would send a good signal to the
private sector because part of this
issue we're talking about is sometimes
economists talk about aggregate demand
as if it doesn't matter where it comes
from I do think it matters whether it
comes from the private or the public
sector and American companies
everybody's read profitable productive
sitting on a lot of cash but they have
uncertainties about some of these
elements so we've talked about I think
something like a social security
solution would help overcome some of
those anxieties so to your point this is
still going to have to be done by
national governments it's not gonna
they're not gonna they're job would be
easier if there were there was some
coordination yes and and and and I think
also the job can be easier if at the
margin institutions like the World Bank
and we're doing this with China would
support it if institutions like the IMF
helped sort of argue that there can be
sort of mutual benefits for parties
doing this and certainly it's better if
people aren't doing things that are
destructive to one another so coming
back to the monetary system you know
wasn't totally accidental that Tim
Geithner went down to Brazil and they
talked about the benefits of flexible
exchange rates because that's raising
the question about China's pegged
currency now having said my own view as
China's should appreciate its currency
but we also going back to one of the
other points I made be wary of silver
bullets they're very hard to find in
life and and I don't think the currency
appreciation alone will drive the issue
yes but but we got in front of us a very
concrete problem because a situation in
Europe what is going to happen I mean
Germany has a large current account
surplus the Mediterranean countries and
Ireland will have to reduce and are
reducing their current account deficits
something will happen with the
and with aggregate demand in Europe so
that the tendency will have will be for
Europe to have a large current account
surplus our friends from Asia are saying
all this takes time we will adjust but
we are not about to change dramatically
any of our policies and that reads we
will continue to have a large surpluses
so here we go again the US has to be the
borrower and the spender of last resort
in the world global economy is going to
continue recovery next year and the
following year and the question is
whether politically that can be the case
in the in the United States and if that
is not the case then I think we will be
in a very conflicted situation that of
course as you say needs domestic
policies which are very complex and
difficult to implement but the job will
be easier if the the work had a system
to to coordinate policies and that takes
me to something that you wrote a few
months ago and corrected graded almost
any scandal in the profession I think it
was on the eve of the Korean that the
g20 summit in Korea you wrote an article
and some people read that article and
said Selleck is proposing to go back to
the gold standard I I have read the
article many times again and you didn't
say that but still you got people so
excited how these you were trying to
speak about the post Bretton Woods
second system you know hint in some
ideas of what a new international
monetary system and you saw a role for
gold and for many other things but you
must have an idea what is that well the
the main battery I'm never the editor of
the Financial Times is a good friend I'm
never sure to be unhappy because he gave
me front-page play which certainly gave
more interest on the other hand it was
an inaccurate headline but nevertheless
let me start this way
one of the points that I actually
included in that op-ed was one we just
talked about and that this shows how
politics and economics could intersect
what I was actually envisioning would be
imagine if before the Seoul summit that
President Obama and president who had
had a press conference and they said and
the part of president who we realize we
have to shift a domestic demand and we
have to increase consumption over
savings and here are the steps that I
plan to include in the 12th five-year
plan to move in that direction they have
said some of these parts the question
would be the degree of further
commitment and give it further in a
sense of momentum and if President Obama
had said in the United States we'll also
need to take these actions and by the
way I believe we have to make sure we're
an open market and I'm gonna pass the
free trade agreements with Colombia
Korea and Panama and try to get the Doha
round on the dynamic that going to the
structural points would have also
created a political dynamic about the
nature of the g20 and this is one of the
other little insides I think when you
have a group like the g20 what will
eventually make it work if it works will
be informal subgroups and they they can
be overlapping
there's Europe they could have North
America you can have the g7 and how the
US and China work together will be very
very important second I emphasize that
as you're going through this transition
period where I believe the dollar will
remain the predominant reserve currency
but over time we may have others that
can be reserve currencies the Euro and
maybe over time the renminbi if it moves
to an open cap lacan let's set some
norms in the g7 finance ministers at a
session that I was at informally and
made the point that their past practice
had been not to intervene in one
another's currencies unless they all
agreed that would be a good norm to
establish in it and then for the
emerging markets at least the big ones
they now face a hot capital flow issue
but one of the things I would suggest
we could work with some of the best
practices or experience about dealing
with hot capital but we should encourage
countries to move towards flexible
exchange rates on autonomous monetary
policies we could have the IMF play a
role as a form of referee not a referee
that has penalties but a referee that
talks about how these different economic
domestic economies are going to affect
one another and I had some other
suggestions of this nature as well
including keeping the eye on the fact
that a structural point of growth is
funded and all not just sort of keeping
the iodine on the exchange rates now the
reference to gold was the following um I
was observing and this is sort of just
in a sense the sceptical intellect over
time that while central bankers hate the
concept of gold and it's seen as
anachronism and clearly I wasn't calling
for a gold standard I wasn't calling for
a formal linkage even as in the
Brentwood system what as I was observing
was that markets were using gold as an
alternative store of value and this was
and I think that this was reflecting
something about their confidence one of
things that was reflecting is they have
a choice of what securities to put their
money in and if they looked at the
dollar or the pound or the Euro or the
yen they were a little uncomfortable the
one they might want to invest in is the
rem MB but they couldn't because it's
not yet an open capital account to
invest in so people were looking to the
dollar and I think the other point was
or the gold I also think that you see
people turning to gold at times of
uncertainty and risk in terms of the
value of true dove paper money in
monetary assets and this is a this is a
warning for politicians as well as
Economist's about both monetary policies
but also a little bit about some of the
fundamentals that we're talking about
say the value of the dollar over time if
you continue to have large deficits so
my point was that if I if I were going
to have the IMF play this referee role I
think it should look at a broad series
of indicators so actually one
commentator said it better than I did
that
as informational value not an
operational value so that was the
context in which I was saying it I think
the attention that it grabbed though
also said something and that in in the
u.s. what it also showed is for some
communities this was a worry about the
soundness of money and that also is
something that people need to keep in
mind okay let me go to the other big
topic and maybe introduce it you have
children
what no ok but do you have a choice
which you cannot say that is not your
child and that is the Doha round worried
my wife is gonna get awful nervous about
this yeah you know in the fall of 2001 I
was at the London School of Economics
but also serving as a pro bono advisor
to Mike Moore the director-general of
the WTO so I was following very closely
what you were doing as you SDR and I saw
very clearly an inflection point in your
activities USTR after 9/11 you started
to be very active and you know speaking
about the necessity number one of given
the administration the US administration
trade promotion activity and more
importantly I would say about launching
a new round at the ministerial meeting
that was going to take place in Doha in
November of that year
and I remember these speeches you you
made which I was reading so I was
following the process where you
basically establish a connection between
the need and the means to combat
terrorism and the importance of
intensifying the effort to open markets
to promote in that specific case the the
Doha round quite frankly the summer of
that year the probability of having a
round launch was very low but yet after
9/11 and I would say to
and because of what you did eventually
the round was launched I was also a
daughter although I to be not very
visible you didn't even notice that I
was there but I was watching you how you
were pushing Pascal ah me who at the
time was a European trade representative
now you were pushing everybody with good
arguments and I would say with good
reasons to have the round launch and you
succeeded so Doha is your child but how
do you feel about your child that is not
concluded it's not over
well first off because it's relevant to
even though ha today I was deeply
engaged with this well before 9/11 and
in fact this is connection with Pascal
Lamy Pascal had been the chef de cabinet
for Jacques de lor the president of the
European Commission when I had been at
the State Department the first time and
I helped put together the elements that
would close the uruguay round so i've
had some background on this about the
international trading system i felt very
strongly when it came in the office
frankly most people thought after the
debacle in seattle that it was too
high-risk to try to launch another round
and in the case the united states we
also had to secure the trade promotion
authority the authority to bring
agreements back for an up or down vote
without amendment and in the u.s. system
the Constitution gives the authority to
Congress so part of the challenge of a
trade ambassador is that you need to
deal with the domestic interests at the
same time as you're trying to negotiate
things internationally and so Pascal and
I actually agreed early on that we would
try to make this happen and we spent a
lot of time a lot of quiet bilaterals
conference calls others trying to figure
out how we could maneuver the different
parties because the challenges you have
to get at that time was about a hundred
and fifty countries two economies to
agree to launch at all at once and the
events after 9/11 was a was a slightly
related I know many people
focused on that but I want to
distinguish that because I personally
think we might have I I think we could
have launched the round without that but
I was trying to make a broader point
that I'll set aside but I think is
important which was you know in the
trauma of after 9/11 realizing this was
going to be a long-term challenge goes
back to my point about America's an open
society that part of the response had to
be to try to help places be open be open
to ideas have economic growth have
opportunity have hope now I don't I
would don't mistake me from saying that
poverty leads to terrorism because if
you look at the background of a lot of
terrorists they're not the poorest
people but I do think that if you have
places that people are broken societies
and people give up a sense of hope these
become the breeding grounds of trouble
so it's trying to make an economic a
political economy argument but there's
also a political value argument about
the openness of societies and how you
encourage people to challenge ideas and
to expand thinking and create a
difference I mean this is part of the
logic of NAFTA for Mexico frankly so
coming back to the launch of the round I
think you know we were able in 2001 to
get it launched we had a we had a
problem in Cancun in 2003 where in my
view it's part of this broader challenge
we had the rise of some of the emerging
economies remember in 2001 you brought
China into the WTO so China felt
understandably it had given because it
actually made a lot of sort of
commitments for the developed economies
they'd often lowered a lot of their
barriers but the China the the Brazil's
the India's the other larger players
were still trying to associate
themselves with sub-saharan Africa which
they're not now one of the things that's
happened in the intervening period
whether it be climate change or
development or or trade is people
recognize the whole concept of a third
world as an outdated concept we have
very different developing and emerging
market economies and I think to be
successful in trade or climate change or
others one's going to have to have some
of these emerging market share
the responsibility I later when I was at
the State Department came up with the
concept of China as a responsible
stakeholder getting the benefits of the
system and sharing the responsibilities
and so I frankly think the 2003 Cancun
moment was a sense where some of the
major emerging markets wanted to waive
the g77 flag engaged in political
advocacy and I frankly think it was a
lost time because Lamia and I as a
European and American sometimes at
loggerheads are working closely together
we over the next months put it back
together and created the fundamental
framework that they're now working on
but frankly then I left off as he left
office we lost the moment I think where
we are now is it comes back to this core
issue I think that many of the countries
now particularly sub-saharan African
countries and others that were uncertain
they want the deal
move forward I think it will depend
heavily on the u.s. sharpening some of
what it really wants or needs to move
forward and get political support and
it's going to require some of the major
emerging market countries to be able to
to meet some of those needs now the u.s.
may have to do some cuts and other
things maybe farm subsidies where farm
prices are high maybe there's less of a
need for these types of things so I
believe a deal is doable I believe a
deal has been doable in the past couple
years but this also reflects a little
bit of how these negotiations work and
just take a moment on this many people
have the idea that it's like a poker
game and you're not giving anything away
and you're gonna walk away with
everything and you're trying to get the
pot on the table it won't work that way
if the other guy is humiliated or has
nothing to go home to sell they're not
gonna sign on so I tend to see these as
multiple joint problems humming
exercises where you're trying to
liberalize as much as you can well deal
with everybody's politics and you can't
everybody can't get everything they want
but you have to try to come up with
multiple solutions and I think that's
what Pascal Lamy he would try to guide
people to do and I I think the key
players now are the ones that I
mentioned very good I have 100 more
questions but I think it's
even late to ask members of the audience
to to pose some questions let's start
with you
and raise your volume do we have a
microphone why don't you go to the
microphone please
and tell me who you are yes please
I'm Co Delta mama I'm according to a
senior Phillip McMillan Center but
people come in here that was a
politician in Japan and I'm a senator
and I was a senator and there was a
deputy minister for economic policy I
was in charge of the g20 after the
crisis and I have a sample pose out
completely
going back to you a very good debate
thank you for the very good has a
dialogue a little and lot who designed
the global economic system from now we
have many issues like cyber state
cyberspace securities climate change
trading system but as you mentioned g20
is a big mess I'm sorry to say but to
many members and to many say so you know
number of the members is the key so I
think the most complete and the large
now has under realistic solution is the
dish a food of the g7 or gg8
so I'm sorry to tell but in kicking out
some members and welcoming new members
up to seven to eight so we have more
than four members from Europe so
allocate I will aggregate such members
into one single boys form Europe so we
have three more spaces for newcomers so
we will welcome
some countries from BRICS Brazil in the
China and I'm sorry to tell Canada
Canada for next time so they can welcome
one member from North America Middle
East so how about this idea
up to seven or eight members and Alicia
Fling g7 g8 and design the system from
now as I mentioned to one of the points
are Nestor made a couple years ago I
tried to suggest about a group
fifteen have some regional bound size of
economies other aspects I think we have
what we have known and I think it would
be one would it's like the UN Security
Council we'd spend a lot of time trying
to decide who doesn't get to come in the
room and it would be a devilishly
difficult task and the politics are
going to be which country you know which
chair then excludes somebody they it's
tend it easier to add somebody than
exclude them I think the way that I
would deal with your concern which is a
legitimate one you get a bigger group it
tends to become less effective is the
one that I mentioned about informal
interaction so I would I would suggest
not seen one group alone in other words
one one looked there's a role for the g7
as I suggested I think the g7 should be
setting a norm in terms of exchange rate
policy that others may move towards we
have the G 187 in the World Bank you
have regional groups APEC ASEAN European
Union I would I think one will be more
successful with a networked model and
then you try to figure out how you bring
together some of the key players to
shape an issue and then bring it as
appropriate to another forum
you mentioned climate change let me give
you a good example the in in climate
change you know I think that there if
there's a core group of countries that
will be most critical for carbon
production I think if one can get that
group of countries to come to some
understandings on some of the principles
it would be easier than to work in the
UN f Triple C process where you have
about a hundred and ninety five players
China had resisted discussion of climate
change issues in the g20 but it has now
opened up on that although it says not
to the exclusion of the UN process so
that allows you to bring issues together
maybe there on the issue like financing
of climate change there would be more
appropriately done through say a group
of finance ministers like that
20 and then brought back to a larger
context so I think we're gonna need to
have the agility it it's a it just it
it's like Yale you have all the
different schools and faculties and
nobody's gonna run it all in a
hierarchical system they're all fiercely
independent but how can we get them to
integrate and effectively together
beyond the president's office well we
are a very open solution more than three
kinds of jobs so we know how to do it
one more question
yes let's go to the back
hi mr. president and victory I'm from
Beijing China
I'm very appreciate you the word Bank
have provided seven hundred million
dollars for help let's quick reading in
China's current promise so thank you
very much so mention that China many
times during your talks
but as do you want to elaborate two
questions we know like China GDP is or
were cheap here in the last year but
also I note like you have mentioned
China economy's lot of dangerous today
so could you kind mean in love and
elaborate like what kind of dangerous in
China economy and also known like after
our the president hooding how visited us
in the past of one month China
I'm beast ass knew about the six percent
appreciation so what's your forecast for
the least yes the iron bees transition
thank you very much if I knew the answer
to the last question I could probably
make a lot of money so I may pass on
that one but first let's take the
context what China has accomplished in
the last thirty years is nothing short
of miraculous and when you look at a lot
of reductions in global poverty and
other aspects it's a it's a huge
accomplishment second one of the
challenges and this is not easy for
China is as you know there's still a lot
of poor people in China it's still a
developing country but because it's been
successful and because it's large people
will look to it to assume
responsibilities whether it's a global
financial crisis or whether its climate
change the us/mexico European countries
they still struggle with this so it's
not surprisingly this is going to be a
transition for China to do this third
aspect I think China's engagement over
this 30-year period with the WTO with
the IMF now what the climate change
negotiation is moving in this direction
it's a recognition of how the
multilateral system serves its overall
interests this is going to be very
important because I think it's going to
be an on
going challenge for you and your college
and others about how do you how do you
explain this to the Chinese people when
people when people are understandably
concerned about sort of immediate issues
within China I think that when you asked
about risks in the near term I think you
know China faces some risks of
overheating asset price bubbles you see
China the People's Bank of China
increasing interest rates they're
experts on the bank supervisory side I
believe these will be managed so I'm not
overly concerned about them but that's a
that's a risk that has to be dealt with
there also may be some risks in terms of
food prices as we've seen and but again
China has the resources to deal with
some of these over a medium and longer
term the nature of the Chinese
development and China's recognize this
put environmental issues secondary and
I'm sure when you go back or when I
visit China in many places you just see
that the environmental costs are very
high so this is going to be a need an
issue that China has got to invest in
and it's investing in pretty quickly we
most of what we do with with China now
is actually bringing knowledge and
experience or running pilots China has
the financing and about 80% of our work
is related to the environment in China
over a medium and longer term this
switch to annex from export led growth
to greater domestic demand and the
structural changes I think will be very
very important for China and it will
also be important so as to make sure
that there's more inclusive growth
you've got some changes in the income
distribution so having people feel that
they're getting the benefits of this now
so far from least what I've seen people
because 10% growth gives a lot of
benefits even people at the bottom end
have seen their life improve but then
this is the next risk I would see in
China and that is not now not this year
maybe not five years maybe not ten years
but if you look at the history of
economies they don't grow for ten
percent forever and some of the problems
that
10% growth hides a lot of problems if I
were looking at some of the asset
portfolios or some of the financial
institutions 5% growth might make him
look a little different than 10% growth
so this will be one of the things that
China will need to prepare for and adapt
for I will say though concluding point
and Ernesto and I were talking about
this I find that one of the things
that's worked very well for China is
that the success to date has made people
confident as it should but it hasn't
made them arrogant and the confidence
allows them to be open to other ideas so
we're talking with China right now about
how to avoid the so-called middle income
trap that many Latin American countries
ran into at 3 to 6,000 per capita
dollars a year and how and and the fact
that China reaches out to us and say we
want to understand how to avoid this
problem I think is a healthy step the
very last point will be a lot of what
Ernesto and I were talking about was the
international system and I do think this
will be a challenge for China just as it
is the United States because many people
in China will say look we're still a
developing country we you know our
incomes are not up and so on so forth
but the responsibilities of the
international system will be thrust upon
China because you're big and influential
so that will be in a sense a challenge
for Chinese politics as well as the
international system well unfortunately
president Selleck you have to catch a
plane in Hartford right Bradley Report
so I have to finish and I know that
there are many more questions so but we
don't have time so all I want to say is
thank you thank you very much it has
been a pretty